we started to predict this months ago
when it became clear that vote by mail
or as
i am now calling it absentee by mail
voting would be a huge dividing line in
the upcoming presidential election
also don't forget it will be a big deal
in the senate
be remaining in republican control maybe
going to democratic control
they are going to be trying to stop
vote by mail and stop absentee voting
they're not even trying to hide it i
already told you that donald trump put a
donor of his name louis de joy
in charge of the post office as
postmaster general we suspected
that de joy would try to hurt the post
office's ability
to deliver mail the joy has already
limited
overtime for mail carriers which is
causing mail to pile up at post offices
across the country
more cutbacks are now being discussed
but now the big breaking news is that
the joy
has reassigned or fired more than two
dozen
top postal officials specifically
two people have been removed 23 have
been reassigned
anyone whose priorities are deliver the
mail
is being moved and instead the joy seems
to be sort of centralizing his power
consolidating the higher echelons of the
postal service with people that are
friendly to his
pro-trump priorities and this is the
mail that we're talking about ladies and
gentlemen if i had told you a year ago
the 2020 presidential election could
come down not to the economy
uh not to donald trump's foreign policy
it could come down to whether
a trump donor succeeds at kneecapping
and crippling the post office
i don't think any of us would have
believed that that was a likely scenario
it's the scenario today and this is all
having an immediate effect there are
already many reports
coming in from around the country about
mail delivery being slowed down and
degraded
there are reports of mail carriers
having to sort mail themselves something
that's usually done for them when they
arrive
and they're ready to take out their mail
for the day it would already be sorted
they're having to sort it themselves
slows them down even more there are
reports of mail bins that should have
been delivered already sitting
at post offices unsorted and undelivered
and the sickest thing of it all
is the backwards logic of everything
trump claimed
that if there were too many absentee
ballots the post office couldn't handle
the volume of mail
the post office said we can handle it
just fine unless
you kneecap the post office which is
exactly what they're doing they are
making it
so that the post office will not be able
to handle even the normal
mail delivery work it's like a trojan
horse
you don't have to be i hope you don't
have to be anti-trump to realize how
evil this is
right right i mean will a pro-trump uh
will will the pro-trump
people in my audience i know you're
there will you come forward and say this
is playing dirty
this is anti-democratic this has to be
stopped it's completely indefensible and
this
they talk about election fraud this
should be called
election fraud so what can we do while
we continue
to sound the alarm on this and demand
that joy
be trotted back to congress to answer
questions
we have to just vote early early early
or
decide we feel safe enough to vote in
person depending on where you live
you within just weeks we'll be able to
make a vote by mail
if it gets delayed five days because of
these cuts it'll still get there in
plenty of time
if you live in a state where you can
believe reasonably that you won't have
to spend hours
in line with maskless people trying to
vote
maybe you decide well i'll vote in
person to ensure my vote is counted
in some places you will be waiting in
line for hours with people without masks
and maybe you don't want to do that and
it makes sense to just vote by mail as
early as you can
all of these problems are by design we
can't let them win
at all but we certainly can't let them
win like this anyone who does not have a
problem with this is complicit in the
eradication of democracy
in this case being done through the
proxy of the us postal service
trump is realizing the race is too
uncertain
unless he rigs it as i said last week
trump might be able to win fair and
square
although unlikely that he would win the
popular vote
he might be able to win the electoral
college fair and square maybe
but it's too close it's too risky and so
they're pulling out all the stops
this is also by the way part of a bigger
republican plan to get rid of government
agencies all together
say that the united states postal
service is not up to the job
then you cut their funding to prevent
them from being up to the job
then you point to the problems you
caused to say you know we really should
get rid of that postal service they're
not doing a good job
look at what they did during the 2020
election we have to be
on red alert because that's exactly what
this is we'll have continued coverage of
this on the david pakman show
instagram at david pakman show we'll
take a quick break
and be right back after this